okay well for people who are joining
this livestream this is a internal
design discussion about a potential
future orphan language feature for
solving and body problems this is
slightly further out than some of the
design reviews we've been doing recently
so let's launch alright now what do we
start on here so let's understand all
right so this means what is one arrow
this this is what is the one that mean
yeah that's a mass that's the mass okay
as opposed to what we're not doing here
is in anyway to tag you know like Earth
Neptune whatever we don't have really a
way to do that do we would we ever be
able to store that not clear I think
actually the that so one of the issues I
think is that we'll we may want to tag
more than one property with with a given
body so we might want to have body tag
names or something because you know for
example in the elastic elastic examples
you need not only mass but material
properties if you're gonna try and do it
using the physics mm-hmm okay so what is
this now and where did these variables
come from oh that was that seems to not
be doing the same thing anymore
right that was probably a print
statement that shouldn't have been there
or something like that okay so let's
take a look here what is this so that is
from the IC from n body evolution data
when it's able to get so if I say data
one of equations are you telling me then
oh that's kind of cool
what about the variables can I ask her
the variables no I didn't write that
could be easily setup but it seems
useful to me yes Irene maybe we should
have variables and that should be an
association which has positions and
momenta could whoever's making that
background noise not do that and the
fact that these are P sub 1 and so on
you know that seems arbitrary because we
will be nice to have peace of Jupiter P
sub earth and so on right
am I making sense yes we could use we
could use whatever we want for the so if
each if each body had a tag of some sort
we could use that as a subscript listen
what I think we should be doing here is
these bodies specifications should be in
the following form so we should have you
know body body tag one arrow and then
each body should be able to be given
something which says mass you know
initial position blah blah blah and that
way we can give arbitrary amounts of
detail about each each body and the
alternative to this would be that we
could just give them in a list but does
anybody remember where I was storing
hold on I want to save this someplace um
remember if this was an N body yes I'm
only problem
okay does this seem reasonable I think
there's a better way to do this so in
general it would be a list of
associations and as the cheap version of
this hey whoever's making that back on
us
please can you stop um
did you understand what I'm saying Rob
yes yes and I think that's better that's
it that's a better way to do it now will
you have to obviously require initial
position and interval velocities but but
you know anything else could probably be
optional them you should let me need a
way to get out the list of the things
that are required for certain potential
models ice what you're saying so yes so
then and what does that mean Rob I think
by the way you're making this background
noise you could try to figure out how to
not do that a bit I'll try um okay so so
let's just look through here so let's
let's be noticing noting down separately
the design here um okay let's put the
sooner okay so the basic thing do we
even believe in the name and body
evolution it's the word evolution the
right word as in big what and Bali
solution wouldn't it be no this this
doesn't emphasize the time-dependent
spot okay so then so then what we're
saying is but here that's the time that
we wanted evolved over right so the the
basic form of this is force law followed
by system set up followed by time is
that correct yes in and you know the
force law can be an association that it
actually has a potential or a force or
different things and I think I included
examples there okay so look the system
set up so by the way I and I assume
units will be able to be handled right
yes okay because we should we should do
the you know Earth Moon Sun system for
example um you know we should be able to
do that with the actual masses of the
particles right and we should move it
sorry go ahead can they move it forward
by giving as an argument to an end body
evolution and body evolution data that
would be nice wouldn't it
so let's think about this um so this
thing returns and body evolution data um
which by the way is rather ugly and its
appearance right now and should be an
actual summary blob yes I know this is
just a prototype Steven okay so then so
what you're suggesting is I mean clearly
that's where it should be is in the
system setup so one possibility would be
an body evolution of force law and then
an body evolution data that makes sense
it seems like a reasonable thing to do
and then that would graph together then
that would make a combined but the force
law could be already embedded in the end
body evolution - I agree I agree in
which case it could just be automatic or
all you just leave out that argument yes
I mean I could imagine somebody I mean I
could imagine the case that people might
want being able to change the force law
it's perhaps obscure but this could be
supported as well but if you change the
force law there do you give the new
power Middle's for what for the force
law review force law well in this first
argument but the film's argument is just
this thing saying what type no I thought
it could be an association giving more
detail about the forgive okay okay so
yes n n-body evolution of just force law
and system setup without our time can
just construct an end body evolution
data with just the initial conditions
ready to go so to speak mm-hmm yes
that's a reasonable thing to do ah right
so yeah I'm sorry with the force law on
a system setup it's not clear back yeah
okay so
okay all right so in more consistent by
the way to say mass position velocity
than to say initial whatever I would
think um by the way we're talking about
velocities why are we talking about P
dot well I don't understand what these
are these are the mentor yes so what I
did what I did in the actual solver to
try and to try and use this this the
symplectic solver is I is I certain
solved in terms of position in momentum
okay but you could have written that in
terms of the momentum could always be
written as a mass times Accu dot yes so
maybe we should say I mean okay so we've
got extractors here or properties and
among those properties and see here
properties so one of those properties
would be I think we should say something
like position equations or something
well no I don't know equations but we
want something why on earth does that
have smart quotes like that how weird
but then we want what are these these
are canonical Michael what are these
called canonical coordinates what are
those called synthetic well okay but I
don't know whether I mean we could say
something like that possibly where
equations is in terms of I mean or that
could be in closed position equations
but precision equations I would expect
that the Q's are eliminated what
happened to these smart quotes and
dispersion that something is wrong with
these smart quotes Oh
[Applause]
somethin okay so what are you saying
here I would expect if you want
precision equation said P I have been
eliminated exactly that's what I'm
proposing yeah but so do you think it
should be called position equations and
then but what should just equations on
its own do have Newtonian so busy
symplectic so that's equivalent to the
hamiltonian equation might be better
less obscure than syntactic equations
and that's equivalent to equations yeah
okay so where do you say where does it
ever say that Q dot is equivalent to the
thing that you call position here in
other words how do I know
let me have a variable as thing argument
precision variables all right
and what velocity variables or momentum
variables these are momentum variables
yeah okay all right let's keep going
here so what's this positions what is
that
totally weird thing so this is this is a
part that's not ideal we need so the
idea is we have this data structure
which you know is useful to get things
like equations and stuff but we want to
get you want to get properties you know
the actual evolution properties at
certain times so so what's the right
design for doing that this is this is
what I set up I realize it's not ideal
okay so let's so this is an end body
evolution data and bed um so what what
background noise so on from our
livestream is asking what about rotation
of objects
I seem to be speaking on you about point
masses not all the personís yet however
it is worth remembering that we might
one day need that possibly also think
about extended objects I mean that
becomes more like a traditional physics
engine
okay in any case let's let some
point particles
okay so so
we've got here is if you just give a
time what should you get
you should probably get a version of
this this thing I think to list you get
a list of precision barriers and mend
Emilio's I don't agree I think you
should get something which really looks
like the system set up for that time
because then you can go in and extract
you know where was Jupiter what was its
velocity and so on that seems like the
consistent thing to do to do if it's
just given a time then it returns you
know a complete system set up for that
time
so it's like the forward evolution like
you're extracting and similarly
presumably if you you give it so what do
we do in is there a way in and II solve
when you get a interpolation function
back do we have some mechanism where you
can ask for like an interval there
in other words did you get what I'm
saying Rob
oh no we don't we don't really have a
way of you you're saying you know reduce
the interpolating function to that
interval that's what I'm saying yes yeah
I mean that's that's this this old
function called function interpolation
sort of does that yeah but what about
just feeding in what about if you just
were to give the interpolating function
an integral an interval why doesn't it
just return another interpolating
function
um something we never thought of
designing I mean what's you know that's
that's that's gonna be that's gonna be
expensive and and what it's gained what
do you mean was it expensive well cuz
you have to reconstruct a whole new
interpolating function by partitioning
and extracting parts of the data okay so
perhaps airy yeah nobody's really asked
for that yeah okay fair enough fair
enough because what what you're doing
then is is you can make a plot okay so
now the issue is what happens if you
want body such-and-such at that time for
example if you only want that body at
that time so then the obvious thing to
do I mean the way you would get that
would be you know body spec
if I'm not mistaken if the thing were to
return an association always then that
form would give you the mass position
velocity for that body and in principle
this would give you the position there
yes that's that's that's correct
um but in terms of actually you know the
way our value works that's not gonna be
a fast or efficient way to get out the
position so if you're doing a plot it's
gonna be quite a few times slower ball
because in bed of time evaluates first
and so some yeah I see them yeah I
understand right so so maybe the right
thing to do here would be to support the
Ilia lighted form of this
and then that can default oh I see body
spec would have to default to all of
them because you really don't know but
this would be so let's see how crazy
this would look so in bed yeah I mean
this is fairly non crazy I mean Jupiter
no I'm sorry time T comma Jupiter the
only thing that's a little unfortunate
about this is I prefer to have Jupiter
position first and then time afterwards
I'm making sense now one way to do that
would be to return here yeah okay so
this is a possibility okay so
[Music]
I'm not suggesting this as such but this
would be so if you did this and then
this returned a spec that said tag one
goes to and then the mass is a constant
so that's okay we can assuming the mass
as a constant which for these
computations that we're doing here the
mass is a constant right then the
position could be an interpolating
function
etc so that would be the complete
solution
am i making sense yes
ah but to slice that for a specific time
so one way to get I see so look this is
this is a way you could do this fairly
reasonably okay
if you said solution comma Jupiter
position then what that would return is
a pure interpolation function that just
has exactly what you want to plot mm-hmm
so being able to say something like so
then in the actual plotting code what it
would look like it's just this so the
only thing that's a little unfortunate
about that is the having to have the
word solution in there
Michael is still with us
mood mood muted but yes vaguely it's a
little bit
it nearly would look nicer if there
would be hours in bed means illusion
goes to Jupiter goes to position also
the end of your coma form well maybe but
I mean I think even better would be not
have to mention solution just say
Jupiter position but more commonly this
will probably have a I mean the other
thing one would want to do is to have a
solution for all bodies um
I did you want you want a couple bodies
but then one one interpolating function
where you stick in the time in the ideal
case
you mean where where the result is of
the interpolation function is a list of
the positions of the bodies court okay
let's think about that for a second I
think we should move on for a minute
actually we have a question from the
livestream can it give particle
positions within a particular geometric
region at a particular time without
having to do all the filtering yourself
afterwards that's certainly interesting
being able to give a region how
that I mean that is being able to answer
the question what bodies are within a
particular region well that would be a
that would be sort of a post-processing
thing for the for the evolution data
presumably yes but I mean the question
is okay fine but but then how would one
how would one even do that
how would one do that how would one keep
only bodies within a particular region
so so using the sign but the way I would
do it you know with with the data I have
now as you would just do you would you
would pass through the bodies and you'd
do basically a region you know region
member kew probably uh if somebody
requested that you would set up a fast
search for it how do you do that
does rita like you have some kind of
region search function well no there's
sort of way it creates a region member
function okay so it's you made it based
visibly so or by the way this is visibly
so you'd remember q what is it cold
region it must be reaching member or
what would one be wanting in terms of a
region in this case you're talking about
like a spherical or a rectangular or
what yeah I mean you want to only look
at you don't care about the asteroid
that escaped from the solar system it
could be at what I'm getting at is would
it make sense just to be thinking in
terms of a straightforward nearest
function where we're using either the
one or two norm for I mean actually on
the livestream someone is suggesting a
region function option for embody
evolution which i think is not is not
foolish um I mean if we allow just what
would this do I don't understand well
but there's a question of what it would
do whether it would actually start
ignoring bodies that went outside that
region that wouldn't make any physical
sense for who doesn't makes it I think
you just want to you could you could
save data only for bodies or in the
region so would be it would be like a
possible way of reducing the amount of
data that would have to be saved I see
that's interesting so so I mean that is
interesting because you could do a big
simulation and then you could say I only
care about the near-earth asteroid so to
speak okay so what was the answer for
where the region member generates a
function here um
oh yeah returns a region member function
that can be applied repeatedly so it
does so okay so that that's an
interesting idea to have a a region
function that um that determines which
things get saved okay let's let's return
though let's take a look more at your
your your notebook here okay kinetic
energy oh wow
I guess that's right I mean I guess this
is physics so I guess we can actually
ask for things like that
and total energy will make kinetic
energies its total kinetic energy or
total kinetic energy in the system or
total what is that clicking I'm not a
physicist and it's showing I think the
energy is fine but I am I think
potential should be renamed to
intellection and potential should be the
one body seeing TEDx and everybody wait
a second so so kinetic energy would be
the total kinetic energy it's that right
of every particle and system yeah okay
um okay and then what is that
interaction energy between between body
1 to 1 3 to 4 and so on okay right now
that's everything there but you might
imagine so that the thing doesn't go
astray in closing the whole thing in a
oscillator potential to keep them at bay
so I'm sorry what's up okay hold on
total energy is something that better be
conserved you know that's the total
energy of the solenoid
you know computed total energy um
which by the way you know you can you
might want very much initially you might
want to say anybody evolution of force
law system set up even before you start
computing with times even in this case
here you might want to say of total
energy and that would compute the total
energy of that configuration
I'm making sense yes yes okay okay so
okay so now I don't understand the
interaction energy this kinetic energy
thing is a single number for every
particle I that seems kind of crazy why
isn't it just the the kinetic energy for
each particle it's the Sun it's the
sound of the system okay then it should
be called total kinetic energy and the
interaction energy is the sum of all the
potential energy I mean
pairwise megabytes potentials all the
potentials are paralyzed we only have
pair potentials
right which by the way is a as a note
for the only deals with pair potentials
you also want we don't want to paint
ourselves into a corner should we go to
a multi pole or whatever it's called
approach to this where you don't
necessarily have all the pairs what do
you mean well with the yes exactly so
you're bright you can approximate the
total very well but you don't even want
to deal with all the pairs that's the
whole point right well so what are we
going to be doing it do we want a pair
interaction energy or do we not yes but
we can always compute a pair interaction
energy it's couldn't somebody who has
back on to conversation but doesn't need
um the UM you can always compute that
right given what we say where we say the
particles are you can always if you want
it compute a pair interaction energy but
the same for the kinetic energy
that what that we might not have
computed it did you like once you have
the momenta you can easily calculate the
toilet energy yeah I mean maybe that's
just a courtesy yes this is exactly boys
of their motor skills C's um but the
pair interaction energies how would we
return that I mean this is just returned
as a number but the pair interaction
things require what just a number it's
just a tutor peer interaction energy of
the system okay yeah and I think that we
definitely want as a total cuz otherwise
we're talking about you know an N
squared matrix yes yeah yeah absolutely
crazy yes right which you can just
compute yourself if you want to okay
this is where it starts getting more
exciting but so it's always do it now if
you've recorded potential what do you
want there like assume you have
something say if you have a commutation
is three body problem yep do it has a
transit one slice to infinity yep
I want to avoid this so I put the whole
thing in an additional oscillator
potential
it doesn't show me okay
so you're changing the potential law no
I ate a one body potential from the
outside and external one to everybody so
that's a completely different thing that
reflects the force law no the force law
is still one over R but but I put
something that constrains to hole sink
but what we're talking about here is
properties you can get out not things
you can put in yes but we had discussed
in last time that we wanted such a one
body zinc fine but then how do you so
that that's okay so you're talking about
an option or a change in that force law
thing there
no the force law is still the same
Steven but okay how do you specify this
it's it's something which this is
nothing to do with an output property so
the way the way the way was put you know
so that's that's input property in the
way like I said that that force law
could be as I set it up in the code and
this was on Michael suggestion is I set
up you could set up an association and
you for example so the default is to
assume a pairwise potential yep okay but
you can but you can put it as an
association such as pairwise potential
goes to that and then I called a
particle potential
goes to whatever lose highly sensible
okay so the force law so you're saying
it could be either something like you
know inverse square um or probably
harmonic potential I would assume you
have that do you know but I have inverse
square oh yes sir I have harmonic
Kristen you know Stephen what they are
identical there's no difference because
Kristen you know Stephen transform every
can be transformed into each other
that's why these are the two exactly
solvable cases because with closed
orbits because they are the same how I
do led relations what what is that
duality transformation Castaignos fever
is that how modern is that is that like
from a century ago or is that a modern
thing fifties huh
is that because so so what's the I mean
the Runge Lenz vector being the
additional conservation law is not
unrelated to the topic attend okay but
so what is the analog so wait a minute
this is like the I don't understand I
thought so
the gravitational three-body problem is
hard I didn't think the the harmonic
three-body problem was hard I thought
that to get like the clothing has to
land no no I was now again the divine
parting is not oh okay okay okay okay
okay okay which is or or the two body
case all right fine okay okay um okay
but so the force law is either something
like this either a named force law such
as inverse-square or harmonic or you're
saying it can be something which has the
form an association which is something
like pairwise arrow whatever is that
correct
yeah I call it pairwise potential but
because they're there there were some
cases where as is actually that Michael
giving me what was actually easier to
actually just give what the force was
just going to say if you cannot always
assume conservative forces okay fine
fine okay so then then we're talking
pairwise so what you're saying here is
that we want something where we can give
pairwise potential pairwise force yes
and if we given a potential will will
differentiate you know will take the
gradient of it yes that's pretty nice
okay so then what what is the yeah you
want the one part
potential what are you calling that I
just called it particle potential yeah
that's that sounds convincing until the
particles of planets well who knows okay
this would be okay that would be the few
points like everybody is in the faucet
of the Sun as outside one you can call
it you could call it body potential
instead ok that's reasonable everyday to
call it external that's much more
reasonable yes because then it could be
like a magnetic field or something okay
door do we have any other things here so
we have pairwise force is that correct
or is it yeah and these things can
either be named or their pure functions
is that correct are they so a pairwise
potential is depends only on the
difference of positions is that correct
or does it depend on the absolute
positions it depends on the difference
of positions
okay so then so in in this case actually
no no that's not true for has to depend
on the norm the the vector between the
absolute vector between the two
positions
okay so pairwise position potential here
depends only on vector difference
between positions it's not obvious that
that's the right thing in general in
general you might want something where
the potential where the pairwise
potential depends on the absolute
positions of the particles right
this is factoring it in some way but
there's nothing about our setup that
really requires you know um I mean we
could have a thing possibly I don't
think this is necessarily right but
something like absolute pairwise
potential or something or position
dependent pairwise potential positional
pairwise potential it depends it a bit
like what are the pure function
arguments if we want to fit in I know I
know
and we could possibly have but I don't
think we want to provide and it's like a
handler function where we don't want to
provide more more arguments than are
necessary right the other size device
potential I feel like ask forgive me -
well so you're saying that this one
would be something where it's F of
position 1 position - what about
velocity dependence there was my next
question
I mean we could have something I mean we
could start with something like this is
getting very I think I know like if you
give more arguments we take as the next
one velocities well fair enough but but
then what about what about the masses
look in the end we're going to have the
complete system set up they're going to
have that whatever the complete tag is
here
we're going to take that association and
actually that is not completely stupid
right if what we did was we gave to
associations to the thing right then
what it would look like as it would say
um well what would it say what we would
like to be able to say is hash
unfortunately if we could say this
I mean unfortunate it's gonna be wind up
being something like that to give the
position of the first body and that's
kind of ugly
right or it's hash one position
- hash - position which is not terrible
all right let's keep looking through
some more of this for a minute here
um so by the way I mean in terms of
these plots it would be really good if
these plots were able to be not you know
if basically the colors were different
because these things correspond it to
now how does that work in parametric
plot so a parametric plot of it has if
it's fed multiple functions then there's
so there's some tricky invocation that
when it when it doesn't evaluate to list
you can tell it to use different colors
and I can never remember what that
tricky I think that should be like one
of the first examples in parametric plot
but it's not well ok down in the options
right fine but we need to them then we
need to look at how to make that better
maybe this is different heuristic for
parametric plot I don't know can um okay
I just want to look through what else
you have here and I want to loop back to
the design um okay this table doesn't
help me very much I mean maybe in the
face base so and by the way this is this
is an N dimensional setup that what
what's happening here is merely that you
are giving it whatever the initial
positions were
um
that's so far dimensionality is
determined by the initial positions yes
okay
why have you got an earth in there it
was just a way of smoothing smoothing it
out so that I could actually do do
something so it's a it's a smoothing
approximation to to what Michael
suggested as a unit step why do you need
that smoothing it gives nd solve a
chance don't you have all kinds of event
mechanisms to deal with this yes we
could we could try to do this that that
that again is a bigger project to do
things like that but yes it's possible
well but let's think about how that will
be specified because this is saying um
you know can you do symbolic analysis of
the force law to determine whether you
have to set things up with events there
should be pretty straightforward you
differentiate and see if you get some
data functions right there's there some
automatic processing part of the reason
I didn't do try to try to you know let
that work here is because I was trying
to use this the symplectic method which
is not really something's that's that as
it's set up now is gonna work with our
current set up with it it's not going to
work with the event stuff very nicely
uh-huh because it requires it requires
constant to keep it simple attic okay to
keep the energy converse conservation
you need to have constant step sizes
right I see
I see well that's okay so then there's
method options yes so I mean you get one
or the other okay so look the hard hard
sphere gas thing is probably a future
umm to a future set of issues alright
let's let's loop back here let's just
look at that parametric plot question
and then let's loop back to this design
I think we're we're getting pretty close
on the design I'm pretty happy with this
I mean I feel like for the default case
parametric God could just be smart and
take the end body evolution data yes why
not
I mean so ok so that plotting um so
you're suggesting parametric plot would
take what the actual end buddy evolution
data open close how could it be open
close it would have to be I mean I mean
no no no no basically a convenient way
would be plot me the whole thing put me
all Partagas of all times given note I
mean that then we should make that work
for interpolating function as well right
which is an interesting idea which we
have not considered because I don't
think we've reviewed this a long time
Rob what do you think about that yeah
didn't I I sort of had this recollection
of Brett doing something with like plot
of interpolation function I don't know
and it just worked maybe it was this
plot there's something he did he'd be
the heed to be the one that knows what
what actually happens but yes ha I mean
part of interpolating function or
parametric plot would have to be an
interpolating function that depends on
no single parameter and produces a list
this is a pretty horrendous example here
sorry what-what are you saying there so
if there is such a usage it is not
documented here no okay okay so I'm
sorry what were you saying Michael
Molesley face were table just said like
depending on what interpolating form
good towards you stick it either in
flawed or parametric blood hmm well
that's interesting but wild but so what
do you I don't quite understand what for
normally interpolation in seeing
something that the rest page that you
have open shows you basically give it
away you get a number back so blood is
the most natural thing to do
but if you give it a normal you give a
pay out back you use for metric throat
yeah but how can you do that if you just
say plot it's not gonna just suddenly
jump into being a parametric plot is it
no no is it I think we all mean the same
thing it's all fine
and if alternative way of doing this
which doesn't doesn't involve messing
with parametric plot or plot or whatever
for the embody evolution is to have just
to have a plot property yeah I just
wrote over okay they didn't know that's
what you meant there's sorry I mean um
the problem with that is what about the
options to plot bear doctor well I don't
know I mean I mean I guess you can do
I'm not convinced about this I don't
think this is the right way to do it but
let's let's go back down here because
there's something that's needed for the
for the basic implementation is to
decide what you actually feed to the
potential functions okay
and in particular when you say
inverse-square you know what is and by
the way I mean when we say Mass we don't
necessarily mean Mass do we we mean we
mean weight of some kind which will
confuse people if we call it weight
multiplier or something because it could
be a charge for example but we use in
some sense F equals MA so M has a very
special status
okay fair enough but what if somebody
wants to do charge they should write
they should they should have charged in
that association fair enough fair enough
fair enough so then that case what what
should happen is that association okay
so then we could have things like charge
here could be another thing there fine
okay so then the what should happen is
that in in the pairwise potential then
the most natural thing to the pairwise
potential to do is to take their a sock
one and a sock too I believe
so how would that actually look I may be
a little bit hot because like Detroit
said you trust edit so we need
non-trivial knowledge how to build the
force from charge no but I'm saying if
you give the pairwise potential there is
okay so this is the first Association
all right so this would be something
like hash one charge times hash two
charge let's let's write it out okay
divided by four PI epsilon zero and so
on so the question is how do you encode
this stuff
well I'm sir I'm suggesting that what
happens is um that we'd say pairwise
potential oh I see you shifted the hung
up sent you to use all yes that's what
I'm saying in this case so let's write
out the whole thing okay so then what
that would be is divided by so we're
wanting the potential we just would then
want to say norm
of hash one position - hash two position
right I mean that seems about as
reasonable as you're going to get
assuming charge two values for torch or
dimension this okay yes Michael we've
got a four PI epsilon zero yeah in there
as well but I'm saying like it's you
they would be not dimensionless then
this would fail now and it would
probably fail we should not
automatically insert this four PI
epsilon zero absolutely not okay that's
absolutely not but we do need to
pre-process these things to get rid of
units right Rob right yeah this whole
thing this whole thing of handling
things like this would be is a
pre-processing step yeah exactly yeah it
just gets rid of all this stuff now the
the default here
would be I mean I think here so
inverse-square means so pairwise but so
just inverse square means gravitational
inverse square and we could have an
electric version of that which expects
charges by making sense yep
should we call it electric inverse
square or Coulomb oh yeah that's right
Coulomb law okay so that would expect
charge I think this is pretty reasonable
and pretty nice actually
so then external potential so this by
the way by giving position literally
here we are dealing with the possibility
that we could have a potential that
depends on the absolute position so it
is not in fact the case that we're
looking at that and we have no reason to
look as that ah and we have no reason to
have that either
and in terms of velocity dependent it's
like who cares we just put it in there
we don't have to specify that separately
so the only point of pairwise potential
is that we're taking every pair here and
we're doing this right so it's like an
outer of those things
yes making sense so in principle one day
we could add a three body potential yep
I mean actually it wouldn't be very
difficult it would be three body
potential actually why are we calling it
pair wise wasn't just pair potential
right
and this could even be triple potential
and then the other one is and so there
would also be pair force and the pair
force would return a vector right yeah
fair potential returns a scalar now
we'll have to choose a sign convention
for the vector namely is is the pairwise
force yeah you know the force of 1
acting on 2 or 2 acting on line I
understand um
okay what's the right convention
I think 2 acting on one it's the force
that one experiences I think two on one
ie force experienced by one yep ok well
that also defines what would happen in
the triple case if we care about that so
now what are we calling so we're calling
it external potential pair potential
triple potential if we have triple
potential um and so these things like
inverse square so we could in principle
say pair wise pair potential arrow
inverse square and then we could say
external potential arrow you know some
random ambient gravitational field or
something yeah ok actually I really like
this way of extracting information now
one question to ask is how does this
correspond to what happens in the system
model of business we should at least ask
those guys Rob do you know the answer to
that
because they have a similar mechanism
for extracting properties of things um
and they have a similar mechanism for
doing a simulation plot type thing so
look I think this is good progress now
how close is your implementation to
something real it's quite a ways
why so numbers of things so so you know
this just calls nd solve and it it just
sort of brute force puts together
equations which for a few bodies is is
not terrible but as you get to more than
just a few bodies it becomes you know
becomes problematic so so the right way
to do this would be to do you know to
write up a fast multipole you know fast
multipole expansion code to actually
I'll compute the compute the right hand
sides yep which is another issue yeah
which is that and this this is this is
this is to me the more interesting part
of it but of course it's the more time
consuming part is so this symplectic
method is designed to work with fixed
step sizes so so mark and I talked about
this a little bit so so if we wanted to
use the symplectic method we could we
could do that but we'd have to do a what
we'd have to do is we'd have to sort of
do an energy monitor and and and when
when you're getting an interaction
that's not sort of being included in the
step the energy sort of goes wacko so
you'd have to sort of go back and reduce
the step size as you get to closer and
closer interactions and I'm not sure how
complicated that would be our other
methods in any Cell will probably get
that correctly but we'll have to be very
careful about you know stiffness because
if the problems do become stiff near
close interactions then we're evaluating
the Jacobian which is absolutely you
know push for these things could be
absolutely enormous right sounds
hopeless right look in terms of a path
forward seems like we should do the
following
we should try to get to the point where
we have an experimental version of this
function that could actually put in that
will work decently for small numbers of
bodies and that has the right design
okay
then separately we need to fork off a
project to do a fast multipole code okay
which can then be basically slotted into
this thing but I think we should debug
the design before you know I mean that
will be a fine thing to fork off but but
I think you know from if we got all the
pre-processing and so on done and all
this design stuff done then we're in
much better shape yes yes that's and I
think we're decently close on this
design I mean we should have another
meeting so let's listen need something
something that you did before I never
got to mention is is the the the total
kinetic energy how do you want how do
you get out the total kinetic energy as
a function of time good question for
that well I was assumed that this is
every one of these things let's think
about that for a second so you had had
the idea here of having this with time
do something it is not completely
obvious that that's a good idea
in other words it might be better to
just not have that case I agree I think
it's better not to have that case okay
and then we might avoid the whole
solution thing exactly exactly
yes exactly so in other words okay all
right fine look let's rethink this for a
second okay so let me just um
okay so then this would be this thing
here with no arguments would be the
whole thing
you
you
now that's kind of stupid too
you
yeah the issue is how do you get out
you
well so this is
all right so let's say that you have um
you've got
ticular body Jupiter or one body number
one position
you
you
you
and that could either have cama time or
it could have of time which would give
you the interpolating function first and
this potentially could be equivalent to
maybe
you
so if that was the case
then the obvious thing to do would be to
have you know then where it's completely
natural that we could say kinetic energy
and what would come out there's an at a
blurring function yes and we can take
kinetic energy comity gives that gives
the particular time yes
someone on the livestream is emphasizing
again that this should be called
embodies simulate and it's not obvious
it shouldn't be and that there's a
there's a
I kind of I'm kind of warming to that
idea and I think um
I think that that would correspond
better to the UM
actually what we have in a different
world is system model simulate do we not
what is it called is this the wrong
version I'm now confused where is that
is it not merged there is a system model
simulator this requires listen the next
one of these meetings we need the the
folks from the system modeler team in
here
you
oh that's funny the personal livestream
is pointing out that n-body simulate has
an N just like n integrate has an N
that's funny
that is funny laughter and ya could have
a double n right um that's funny and not
necessary ever have an exact version
what's that I don't think we would ever
have an exact version well that's yeah
people say the three-body problem can't
be solved right it unless we give one a
Sunderman solution or something yeah
which would be funny but if not very
useful um okay but but but there is a
system model simulate um
yeah there we go system model simulate
which actually is somewhat analogous to
this
actually this is interesting I mean this
is still experimental but this is
interesting to take a look at as a as a
sample of how one thinks about this
I mean I do assume that we don't already
have code in there for doing this
problem
you
it's very uh nobility so notice that
system model simulate returns
system model simulation data and then
has a system model plot that does this
where you can tell it I want to see
these particular variables
and it plots over the complete
integration range
you
and that's a reasonable actually a
reasonable way to do them the plot
there's a parametric pot I know but but
but we want to do it I mean we can't
have a very special plotting function
just for embody problems
all right so this this we have to look
at and can we make sure next time that
we include the system model of folk in
this design meeting and I think though
that we are you know Rob you should be
in a position to actually update your
implantation to correspond to what we're
talking about here yes I think I can do
that it's you know there's let's the
suit
there's there's still some issues but I
can certainly update it to to do that I
mean most of the work isn't doing the
the parsing of the functions right which
I think we're we're looking fairly good
on all right sounds good let's wrap this
up um very nice really very nice okay to
be continued wait a minute somebody is
just I'm sorry
oh there somebody's asking a completely
different question about server farms
for WolframAlpha um it's interesting I
don't even know where we are in the in
the as a matter of fact my very next
meeting which I'm afraid is not going to
be live-streamed
has to do with Wolfram Alpha which fully
I so I will ask that question there and
if we get an answer asks question again
on another live stream and we'll try and
answer it all right um got to go here
okay thanks a lot guys